[Music]
sids in memphis hi sid how are you
hey dave huge fan uh
how are you doing great man how can we
help
yeah um so me and my fiance are in a
little rut um
she got in an accident back uh
right before christmas of last year
um
and it was during the time where i was
also out of work with kovid i was out of
work for about uh
six weeks
and she ended up getting in an accident
they determined her 50 50 at fault
then
carl was totaled out she still had a
lien on the car
for sixteen thousand dollars should i
have insurance
uh she was currently in between
insurances uh she was switching over
from i think she was with progressive
and she got a better rate what did she
cancel why did she cancel one before she
got the other in place
well she didn't cancel she was switching
them over but before they switched her
over they said that she had some
some 200
fee
uh before she could switch over but it
made no sense to us because she went
ahead and paid six months in advance
uh and i i don't understand where the
200 came from
uh every time i tried to contact them
before the accident i had asked i said
where is this 200 coming from they said
well we'll transfer you over to someone
that may help be able to help you and it
just disconnects the line
uh why don't you just cancel the
insurance and go buy some i mean you
don't need to be running around that car
insurance so what how much does she owe
on this direct wreck
the wreck
she was uh like i said it was 50 50 at
fault she still had 16 000 left to pay
on her car
um
and
they towed it to wrecker and they were
holding on to it in the meantime
from what the report said
it seemed like the other person was at
fault because they turned on a green
with no protected turn
and she was going straight she turned
out in front of
my fiance and they said no she's 50 50
at fault we're not going to cover
anything on her car
so that that entire ordeal took about
another month and a half and
you know just going back and forth with
them and in that month and a half
storage fees are crude
um
the payment's still due on the car the
storage fees went up to around uh
2500
on top of what uh
what was owed on the car i was out
for
uh like i said six weeks with covid so i
had to start dipping into savings just
to make ends meet
and
uh
she's in the process
of filing for bankruptcy oh crap no whoa
whoa whoa
you don't file bankruptcy on sixteen
thousand dollars
uh-huh
no
has she signed the papers
no no don't sign them
that's absurd
absolutely not is she working
she only brings in about uh uh 950 to a
thousand dollars a month why
uh that's just what they pay her right
now why i told her why does she stay
there that sucks
yeah uh
i i have no idea i i guess she's just
gotten so used to being there
i don't know
i told her she's need to she needs to
leave
and get how old are you guys
uh i'm 25 she is 24. when are you
getting married
uh we've pushed it back we had it set
for next year winner of next year but
we're pushing it back because of this
whole situation
yeah what do you make
i make about 3 000 a month i work in
construction okay
all right and we also have two kids
together we have a six-year-old and a uh
and uh three-year-old i'm sorry a
five-year-old you need to call you need
to call a pastor and go get married this
weekend
you're completely married you have kids
you're living together you're doing
everything else and the fact that you're
not married just silly
you need to get you need to you know
that you're pushing this back and saving
up for a wedding it's just dumb on a
rock i mean you need to get your go
ahead and get this done all right and
this is killing y'all and uh uh hum and
so you got a big daycare bill
uh yes yes okay
all right so
she's gonna she needs to change careers
and you need to pick up an extra job and
then you need to start negotiating a
settlement with the storage guy and with
the car
and get rid of the car get the car gone
get start working with the bank and
settle with them you can probably settle
this for
you know probably sell a storage bill
for a quarter of what he's asking and
probably settle the car deal for a
quarter what they're asking because you
know you don't have any money and
they're about to repo the car tell them
to get the car repo and get it sold and
get off his lot
or tell him to get rid of it i don't
care somebody needs to get rid of it
here's the thing everything you
described in this whole story
everything happened to you all because
you were passive and stood around and
watched it all happen
all right you stood back and expected
this to like the calvary was going to
come and fix this for you you got to get
game on here man
game on
like get this mess cleaned up yesterday
get some new jobs get some new income
coming in yeah get this car done get on
get on the phone with the storage guy
and go look what do we do to get rid of
this car i don't know how to do it but
i'm done and i'm not paying you two
thousand dollars i'll work with you but
i don't have any money i'm a poor
construction worker with a couple of
kids and i ain't gained money so good
luck collecting that no we're not
following bankruptcy on 16 000
you guys are in this mess because you've
been passive and watched all this stuff
happen to you and you need to get like
in engagement mode on every one of these
issues first you were passive and stood
around watch the insurance run out which
caused the whole mess and waiting on
somebody over 200 and then you got hung
up on and instead of just firing their
butt and going and getting a new
insurance guy you're going well i got
hung up on so now you don't have
insurance you got to go get insurance
right now every mim every minute that
you go without car insurance you're
asking to get in this kind of a mess but
now you're there so every minute you
don't deal with a storage guy every
minute you don't deal with this car
company and every minute you don't go
see the pastor and get married and every
minute she stays in this stupid but
horrible job that she's got is
ridiculous
she's making nothing in a culture where
freaking targets paying 20 an hour
20 an hour go work at target go work at
walmart they're paying 15 an hour a
whole lot more than she's making yeah
there's a lot going on here sid but what
i'm hearing overall we need to be
proactive instead of reactive you guys
are letting life happen to you letting
murphy just take over you got to own
your life get a fire under your butts
get those jobs get this debt cleaned up
and realize bankruptcy is not the answer
this is not the fix that you think it's
going to be
please don't
sixteen thousand dollars and if she
needs some encouragement have her listen
to the fine print episode eight is
bankruptcy a quick fix for struggling
americans i think that will get her to
step away from this ledge yeah and and
well you know you're not bankrupt you're
broke there's a difference and you don't
you don't you're not making any money
and you're not aggressively handling
stephen covey in his book the seven
habits of highly effective people
says the number one habit of people who
are highly effective number one of the
seven is they're proactive
they happen two things things don't
happen to them
and so everybody gets victimized by
something different times in our lives
everyone has stuff happen to them that
happens all the time but living that way
is a pattern
is gonna cause you nothing but stress
and pain
and so you're gonna have to switch the
script on this write a new story as john
deloney says
hang on we're gonna send you a copy of
ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose for her to read because she
needs a new job and you need an extra
job some more overtime so you're making
more money
instruction's booming right now